he's david carr former nfl quarterback
nfl network analyst and uh
you can watch david thursday night
football continues
tomorrow night dolphins jags exclusively
on nfl network
good morning how are you good morning
dan how are you
i'm doing okay when you watch your
brother play on monday night
can you watch and relax and enjoy a game
where your brother is
playing no absolutely not i was sweating
two hours after that football game
because i have i have literally no
control over what happens
i mean the last time you took advice
from me was like when he was 14
so like i have no say in anything that
happens on the field
but what would you tell him like
even though he may not listen to nothing
nothing yeah yeah at this point nothing
i mean honestly like
when you when you watched him play he
has such a such a command at the line of
scrimmage like him and john did such a
good job the other night
the saints did a good job early give him
some different looks kind of changing it
up because they know that he's going to
audible pretty much every play so
but once they got in the groove it was
it was it was just amazing to watch
because like on third down like you can
say what you want about their offense
about how you know it's maybe short or
intermediate they get the ball out of
their hand fast a lot of completions you
know the yards per attempt has always
been a common theme but since 2016
tom brady did this no one has had a
higher quarterback rating on third down
and then again this year in the first
two games derek's quarterback rating on
third down 141.4 so that's like the
level playing field we need
seven yards they're the best in the
league at getting that first down so
i just watch and kind of say man i wish
i had that kind of command i wish had a
coach that believed in me like that i
mean offensive line played seller
they lost richie incognito they had
trent brown on the sideline i mean i
know they talked about michael thomas
not being there but
man they were depleted and they still
ran the ball when they wanted to
played physical on defense it's just fun
to watch man i watch as a fan now
but why is it it feels like the raiders
haven't been all in with your brother in
recent years
you know that's just a that's just a
it's media it's out there and that's
what's so frustrating with him like he
gets in
training camp and he just goes on this
rant when he goes and gets a chance to
talk to the media and he says i'm tired
of being disrespected
because he feels one thing from the
inside so when mike mack and
and i or when when he's talking to mike
and when he's talking to john it's like
all in we're gonna fix this thing we're
gonna do it right you're our quarterback
everything from the inside is there
completely sold on him
and then on the outside he hears oh well
maybe they'll go pick up a quarterback
maybe they'll do this in the first one
they've had like seven different chances
to draft the quarterback in the first
round they haven't done it so
and you know john he loves quarterbacks
so he's gonna go grab one if he feels
like he needs one
so i mean for derek that's the
frustrating part is what's
what's happening on the inside and
what's happening on the outside are two
completely different things
as an analyst what would concern you if
you're a raider fan with this team
well defensively is the thing that i've
kind of had a concern for for a while
you watched that first half of that last
game it looked like it was about to be a
wrap michael thomas is tweeting this is
going to be a blowout i mean i'm i'm
sitting there thinking yeah he's
probably right you know so they finally
turned it around played some physical
football
jonathan abram is interesting because
he's kind of a tone setter there so you
watch taysom hill they go they put him
at quarterback
he runs his own read and he gets his
head knocked off by jonathan they don't
run that anymore
and it almost was like a little bit of
an igniter for that defense to kind of
say okay
we're just going to play physical we're
going to fly around we might make some
mistakes we'll give up some plays but
if we can lock it up in the red zone get
an interception right before half
you know you just got to be
opportunistic you don't have to be a top
10 defense if you got an offense like
they're going to have
you don't have to be great you just got
to get the ball back steal it from drew
right before the half go get some points
and then just try and survive because at
the end of the game i was i'm sitting
there thinking if we're not up 10
you know inside two minutes we don't
have a chance and fortunately enough
they're up two scores
what do you make of the drew brees tired
arm
controversy well it's it's a real thing
because i mean it's
it's just it's it's father time you
can't defeat that
as as strong and and as as well as drew
works in the off season
you know you can't combat that the
problem is and here's what i see
is his brain is writing checks that his
body can't catch so like the
interception that he threw right before
the half
10 years ago he drops that ball right
over the top of monroe and it's probably
a first down
it's probably exactly where he wants to
go but and i've been there especially
when i go out and throw now
you go to throw the ball your brain says
this is what i need to do this is the
kind of
you know energy i need to provide here
and then it comes up 10 yards short and
you're like what happened
and that's it's just part of the game
and he did that he did that consistently
the first
first week did that again against the
raiders he did it a little bit last year
too we just kind of didn't really notice
a little bit you know we talked about it
a little bit but
it's just one of those things that he's
going to have to just work through
because it's not it's not going to get
better you know but he's still sharp he
still knows where to go with the ball
he knows what play to get into i mean
that stuff's not going to go away if
anything it's going to get better
you know the more reps but the you know
it's kind of like that you know mentally
and physically he's already missed that
peak he's on the way down so
it's going to be a tough thing to watch
i love this on monday night dan orlovsky
of the mothership
former uh backup quarterback in the nfl
he tweets out
if uh derek carr won't be aggressive on
third in one play action
pass with rugs on the field in man
coverage he's never going to be
and then david carr tweets relax dan
i just had to and then my wife asked me
are you fighting with janorolovsky i'm
like no i'm not fighting with daniel
he just said some dumb thing that i had
to comment on because they ended up
going off in the score and doing
whatever they wanted to
so look so like that play in particular
like i i don't have a chair i don't have
a headset on during the game we can't
tell people this but it is it's a third
in one
you know you got rugs he's actually
being doubled if you watch the end zone
he's
being doubled by the safety in the
corner and witton is being guarded by a
linebacker now witten because it's man
coverage off the play action the
linebacker steps up for the run misses
the fact that winton releases so the
safety of being a smart player says well
someone's wide open so he leaves the
middle of the field looks like henry
ruggs is wide open for a touchdown
derek's already let the ball go for the
first down so it's just one of those
things that happens bang bang but
the camera catches at a certain time
they're trying to get rugs involved i
mean he took
two shots to him later took a shot to
him ended up winning the game to ginoris
down the sideline if jenkins doesn't
grab him you might have a big play there
so
you know they're going to work him in
there but he's a young guy it takes a
while for young receivers to kind of
figure it out but he's got
plenty of ability they'll get him going
he's david carr the nfl network analyst
former nfl quarterback thursday night
football
on the nfl network it's dolphins jaguars
am i the only person who ever pointed
out that your brother looks like the
lead singer uh you know billy joel
armstrong of green day
you have you have pointed that out
numerous times i know but am i the only
guy who ever did that does billy joe
armstrong think that your brother looks
like him
it's the eyeliner dude you know
it's the natural eyeliner
are they both wearing eyeliner no well
definitely billy is
and i mean i'd love to say like as an
older brother i would absolutely love to
say yes derek's wearing eyeliner but i
can't i can't do that
i mean i can't do that that's not what
he's doing man he's a football player
that's one of those where
he came on and i said does anybody ever
tell you look like the guy from green
day he goes
no and then all of a sudden yeah
everybody
yeah um what do you do with the chargers
if you have you you saw this little i
mean unbelievable performance by justin
herbert
but then anthony lynn says no he's a
backup and
tyrod taylor's our quarterback tyrod
taylor's got a lot to live up to
this next game compared to what justin
herbert did
so no doubt about it and well that don't
ask me because i'm playing the rookie
i'm playing that young kid because that
was outstanding the throw he made to
keenan allen on third and 14
down the middle of the field as he's
getting hit from the right side right
tackle this
block lord kind of just doesn't get
enough of him that was the best throw we
saw
sunday i mean it was but hands down you
know and so that's what he's done a lot
of organ throwing those vertical seam
type routes
he made some bad plays like on that
actual drive he takes a sack
ends up being second and 24 shouldn't
have taken the sack dump it out okay so
he messed up
the next two plays he rips it to the
tight end picks up 10 yards rips it to
keenan picks up another 14
they end up getting a field goal sends
him into overtime later because of those
three points that he got so
i mean he went toe-to-toe with the world
champs and he played pretty well so i
think that honestly i think what
happened was
you know because of whatever happened
with tyrod before the game
and maybe you know the reason he
couldn't go is because maybe some
medical things that was going on i mean
i think they could just feel bad you
know because
okay we might have messed up here we
can't just take tyrod's job
because maybe we did something wrong so
i think there's a little bit of that
you know honestly and and that's kind of
what they're working through because i
think that
if anybody watches that game you know
you got a good enough defense justin
gives you a real chance
to go out there and make some kind of
splash plays he'll make some mistakes
but he'll learn from it he had a smile
on his face
i loved watching him i thought he did a
great job well it's the same thing with
tua at what point
do you let to a play because ryan
fitzpatrick is not your quarterback next
year
does he play tomorrow night i hope so
i mean i think that chan galey was
brought in for this very reason to have
too as a quarterback i mean this thing's
been in the works now for
multiple years you know you bring chan
galion because he's kind of the rpo guy
from like back in the day he was doing
it before anybody you know you make an
offense that's quarterback friendly
now granted fitz can play i mean i i
love the beard i mean i
i came out i watched this guy play you
know we kind of grew up together
right no nothing against fitz but it's i
think tua can get into this system
and he's not gonna he's not gonna hurt
you you know he's gonna if anything he
might amplify what you got going on so
and he's gonna fit perfectly in this
scheme that you have hand tailored for
him so
the only thing that i can't answer that
we probably can't answer sitting here
is how ready is he mentally because we
didn't see any pre-season games we
didn't get a chance to see
as he picked it up does he understand
how's his hip feeling like all those
little things that we probably don't
know
you know that's probably the only reason
that's holding them back if i said you
have one game to win
it's a playoff game and you pick anybody
in the nfl right now
who would you pick at quarterback yeah
besides my brother because he's great on
third down we just mentioned it would
you take
your brother over russell wilson
patrick mahomes so on no honestly so
like
when i watch russell wilson play and i
heard last week
that he hadn't ever received an mvp vote
i stood up out of my chair and walked
out of the living room i was like i had
no idea yeah and that's just kind of
crazy to me and i don't know he's in
seattle
so not a lot of people get to see him
they have a great win week one no one
really even talks about it
but he's he's as dynamic as quarterback
as we've ever seen he does
everything everything you want if you
want to throw it quick
if you want to throw it with pressure
you want him to move he wanted to run
zone runs you wanted to throw the ball
down the field
he's better than everybody at pretty
much everything and i i love his makeup
i love what he brings to the table i
think i think right now he's the best
quarterback in the league you know it's
easy to say after watching the first
couple weeks but
i've felt that for a long time i have a
top 15 that i do every week russell
wilson's
never been out of the top five he is
always right there just because of what
he brings to that football team and now
he's got some guys around him dj
you know you got jamal on defense so you
get the ball back a little bit more
i think they got a real chance to do
something longest career run
you or your brother who has the longer
one oh my goodness well i know we
roasted him for a while because he never
he didn't have a rushing touchdown for
like the first five
years of his career but longest rushing
i don't know i might have had like a 20
yarder or something maybe 25 yarder he
definitely
you had he has one six you had a thirty
second
yeah he might have had one i think he
had one early maybe his rookie year that
was
made maybe 40. yeah is that right yeah
41.
yeah that's frustrating i know because i
remember he broke
kind of past the 30 and i was like
really you're
gonna take that from me but do you make
fun of him because he didn't have a
rushing touchdown for five years oh my
goodness
oh oh my god i'm like dude you have the
power to call to audible to a
quarterback sneak at any time
you've been on the one like 20 times
just
just brady's always calling his number
one time every time and then when i
played against peyton when i was back in
houston
every time peyton is either going to
call a pass play on the one yard line or
quarterback sneak he's not giving it to
the running back
james he should have 50 more touchdowns
than he had but but how angry do running
backs get
when quarterbacks get to the one yard
line and they want to do a quarterback
sneak
they give you the pat on the head but
it's with a little bit more aggression
you know and you're like yeah i know i
did that to you that's my bad dude
plus those those one yard pass you know
those touchdown passes too
that hey they still count they still
count touchdowns you go back and look at
peyton when he threw 55 touchdowns
whatever it was there were 35 of them
were inside the pvr line so
whatever hey it's great to talk to you
david as always we really appreciate
your insights thank you
that's uh david carr that's a good
appearance there nfl network analyst
former nfl quarterback
and a great athlete quarterback in his
own right